PUBLIC NOW I AM FORTUNATE TO
PRESENT A BILL AND MY BILLS LAST
BILL FOR ANOTHER COMMITTEE RIGHT
NOW WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR
QUORUM SO.
HOPEFULLY BE BACK WITHIN TEN
MINUTES AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE
CORN SO JUST WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON THANKS
.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS THE
WEDNESDAY MARCH TWENTY SEVENTH
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE.
AT THIS TIME WE STILL DO NOT
HAVE QUORUM SO WE'RE GONNA ASK
FOR ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO PLEASE JOIN US BUT IN THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WE ARE GOING
TO BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND WITH THAT -- I WILL WAIT
UNTIL WE HAVE QUORUM TO CALL
ROLE BUT WILL ASK OUR FIRST
AUTHOR.
FILE ITEM FIVE AB FOR ELEVEN
MISTER STONE IF YOU WOULD LIKE
2%
BUT IT.
I HAVE REVIEWED THE ANALYSIS OF
AB FOR ELEVEN AND PROVIDES GOOD
ANALYSIS I WON'T COMMENT ON THAT
AND I'LL KEEP THE REST OF MY
COMMENTS.
VERY BRIEF BECAUSE I KNOW YOU
HAVE A FULL AGENDA TODAY.
PRIOR THE DISSOLUTION OF
CALIFORNIA REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ
THROUGH ITS REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
HAD CONSTRUCTING NEARLY. TWELVE
HUNDRED TWELVE HUNDRED HOUSING
UNITS IN THE CITY. THREE HUNDRED
AND SIX OF THESE FOR VERY LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY ONE REFERRED LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS.
THIS IS A REMARKABLE RECORD FOR
CITY OF JUST SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
AGAIN IT WAS TWELVE HUNDRED
UNITS UNFORTUNATELY.
THE ABRUPT DISSOLUTION OF THE
CITY'S REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE LEFT A
NUMBER OF OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS STRANDED.
IN ONE OF MS STILL STRANDED
TODAY.
AND SINCE THAT TIME ALSO SANTA
CRUZ HAS BECOME ONE OF THE
LESSER AFFORDABLE COMMUNITIES IN
A HOUSING MARKET IN OUR NATION.
IT'S GREAT HAS A GROWING UC
CAMPUS AND IT'S VERY
EXPERIENCING THE HOUSING
PRESSURES OF SILICON VALLEY.
WHAT IS ALSO UNIQUE ABOUT OUR
CITY IS A WE STILL HAVE
AVAILABLE STAFF TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YOU'RE
LOOKING AT TWO OF US RIGHT HERE?
WE ARE PART OF THE RECORD OF
TWELVE HUNDRED UNITS WERE PROUD
OF IT AND WE'D LIKE TO DO A
LITTLE BIT MORE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
WITH THE FUNDING FROM A. B. FOR
ELEVEN WE CAN START TO PROCEED
ON SOME OF THESE PROJECTS AND
WHAT ARE THESE PROJECTS. ONE OF
THEM IS A LARGE TRANSIT CENTER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT RIGHT
NEXT TO THE TRANSIT CENTER.
IN IT'LL BE ALMOST ALL ENTIRELY
AFFORDABLE IF WE RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE LIKE A BEFORE.
ELEVEN THERE ARE OTHER SOME
OTHER PROJECTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THAT MAY COME ONLINE
AND WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THEM IF THEY'RE ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR OWN
FINANCING.
BUT EVEN MORE IMPORTANT THE
FUNDING TO AB FOR ELEVEN WILL
ALLOW US TO MEET OUR REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ALLOCATION.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT IN
THE PAST WITH REDEVELOPMENT AND
NOW WE'RE CHALLENGE WITHOUT IT.
AS THE PROVISIONS FOR THE
HOMELESS HOUSING IN A BEFORE
ELEVEN SANTA CRUZ IS THEIR
PRIMARY RESIDENTIAL PROVIDER OF
HOMELESS HOUSING IN OUR COUNTY.
AND RIGHT NOW OUR CAPACITY HAS
BEEN REACHED IF YOU COME IN YOUR
TOWN YOU'LL SEE A CAMPSITE.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE LIKE
MANY OTHER COMMUNITIES AB FOR
ELEVEN WILL HELP US ASSIST THAT.
AND MOVE FORWARD ON SOME NEW
HOUSING RESOURCES FOR IT.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT A BEFORE.
ELEVEN KATHY NEIER HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND WE'LL
GIVE YOU SOME SECRETS TO OUR
ABILITY TO DO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IF YOU NEED ANY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WE LOVE
YOU TO SUBMIT THE SECRETS IN
WRITING TO ALL OF US -- WITH
THAT UNLESS OR ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COLLEAGUES LET ME ASK IF
THERE ARE -- HE IF THERE ARE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION. SIX SCENE NINE OUT
WE DO NOT YET HAVE QUORUM WE ARE
ONE VOTE SHORT BUT AS SOON AS WE
DO WE WILL -- ANYTHING THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SAY IN CLOSING LET
ME ACTUALLY JUST A VERIFY
BELIEVE YOU HAVE AGREED TO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT.
WE'VE DISCUSSED YES THANK YOU
FOR A REALLY APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH YOUR STAFF ON THAT WE HAVE
AGREED TO THE MEMBERS THAT ARE
LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND WITH THAT I'D TO US HERE I
BOTH GREAT AND THAT -- I'M VERY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL I
THINK WE ALL KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO MAXIMIZE THE USE OF ALL
AVAILABLE FUNDS.
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING DURING
THE CURRENT CRISIS AND WE DON'T
WANT FUNDS TO BE SITTING ON YOU
SO HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT WE WILL
TAKE A VOTE WHEN WE HAVE COR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S CALL UP OUR NEXT AUTHOR
FILE ITEM THREE MISTER CHAPMAN
AB.
SEVENTEEN THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I I LIKE TO START DAHLE BY
ACCEPTING AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE FIVE OF
THE ANALYSIS. TO REQUIRE H. CD
TO REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ALL
WITH AN ANALYSIS OF THE PROGRAM
AND ALSO TO REQUIRE EACH CD TO
CREATE A NOTICE ABOUT THE
PROGRAM.
THAT PARK OWNERS CAN USE TO
INFORM RESIDENTS ABOUT THE
PROGRAM.
AB ONE SEVENTY THREE PROMOTES
THE ACCURATE TITLING OF MOBILE
HOMES BY EXTENDING THE SUNSET
DATE.
ON THE REGISTER YOUR MOBILE HOME
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM WHICH IS A
FEE AND ABATEMENT PROGRAM UNTIL
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO MOBILE HOMES
ARE REGULARLY SOLD ON A SOMEWHAT
INFORMAL BASIS.
A PROBLEM ARISES WHEN A BUYER
SUBSEQUENTLY TRIES TO TRANSFER
TITLE INTO HIS OR HER NAME AND
THEN DISCOVERS THAT THE PREVIOUS
OWNER FELL BEHIND ON THEIR TAX
BILL.
THE BUYER IS UNABLE TO PAY DOWN
THE TITLE CANNOT TRANSFER.
AS A RESULT SOME BUYERS ARE IN A
SITATION WHERE THEY PAY FOR
THEIR HOME BUT YET HAVE NO
MEANINGFUL PROOF OF OWNERSHIP.
WHICH COULD CAUSE A HOST OF
OTHER ISSUES SUCH AS THE
INABILITY TO LEGALLY MAKE
REPAIRS TO THE HOME. TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED -- AB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH
ESSENTIALLY ESTABLISH A TAX
ABATEMENT PROGRAM CALLED THE
REGISTER YOUR MOBILE HOME
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
OF FOR HOME A MOBILE HOMEOWNERS
WHO ARE WHO ARE UNABLE TO
TRANSFER TITLE OF THEIR HOMES
INTO.
THEIR NAMES DUE TO TAX
DELINQUENCIES THAT MAY HAVE.
BEEN A CURB BY PRIOR OWNERS.
THE BILL PROVIDED ELIGIBLE
HOMEOWNERS THE ABILITY TO APPLY
TO APPLY FOR THE ABATEMENT
PROGRAM WITH THE H. CD.
OUR IS A MOBILE HOME IS ON THE
LOCAL TAX A PROPERTY TAX SO THAT
IS L. P. T. SYSTEM.
THEN THE COUNTY TAX COLLECTOR IS
INVOLVED IN PROCESSING AND
APPROVING THE TAX ABATEMENT.
THE BILL FURTHER REQUIRE SELLERS
TO OBTAIN A TRANSFER CLEARANCE
TITLE OF FROM THE CD INDICATING
THAT EX CD.
IN FACT THE MAY LEGALLY AMEND
THE TITLE PRIOR TO ANY SALE.
NOW SINCE THE PROGRAM STARTED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN APPROXIMATELY
TOLL A TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN MOBILE HOME OWNERS
HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE.
OF THE PROGRAM WHICH HAS
RESULTED IN MOBILE HOME OWNERS
SAVING OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THE PROGRAM IS ON PACE TO SAVE
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS ABOUT TO THE
TWO MILLION DOLLARS BY THE TIME
IT AT SUNSETS ON DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY NINETEEN DESPITE
THE SUCCESS THERE.
THERE ARE STILL TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMEOWNERS SO WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PROGRAM.
THIS BILL AB ONE SEVENTY THREE
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET ON THIS
PROGRAM. FOR THREE YEARS TO
CONTINUE TO HELP -- MOBILE
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
TRANSFER -- TITLE OF THEIR HOME
INTO THEIR NAMES DUE TO TAX
DELINQUENCIES THAT THEY MAY HAVE
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN INCURRED BY
PRIOR TO OWNERS.
OF WITHOUT AYE A HEALTH -- TWO
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY TO SUPPORT
THE BUILT OUR MISTER BRUCE
STANTON AND ALSO MISTER ROGERS
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR.
ALL THAT IS THE GOLDEN STATE
MANUFACTURE HOMEOWNERS TO LEAK.
SO WITHOUT A LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO THE TWO GENTLEMEN AND
BEFORE YOU WENT AS A STAR LIKE
TO ESTABLISH QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. TO HEAR TO HEAR DEEP.
DEEP HERE GABRIELLE.
GABRIELLE HERE GLORIA.
KILEY LEE MOM.
LIMóN HERE MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTION HERE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HERE AND SINCE WE
HAVE COR LIKE TO ALSO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES I COULD HAVE A MOTION.
THE GROUP BY MISS THEM ON
SECONDED BY.
MISTER YEP MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CHIU THERE ARE CHU LAI TO IT
DEEP.
YES.
HI GABRIELLE GABRIELLE I GLORIA.
KILEY.
LEE MON.
THE ONE I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE YOU CAN RULES
ARE ADOPTED -- LET'S GO BACK TO
THE BILL PRESENTATION AND TO
YOUR WITNESSES.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ROGER JOHNSON.
AND I LIVE IN A MOBILE HOME.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE GOLDEN
STATE.
MANUFACTURED HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE
KNOWN AS GSM.
KNOWN AS GSM WHILE -- I'M
REPRESENTING SENIORS VETERANS
IMMIGRANTS AND FAMILIES WHO LIVE
IN MOBILE HOME PARKS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO CLARIFY.
THAT THE PROPOSED MEASURE IS NOT
AN AMNESTY.
THAT IS.
THAT THE OPPONENTS CALL IT.
IT IMPLIES IN THIS CASE A
COMPLETE FORGIVENESS OF TAXES.
RATHER THIS BILL IS A WIN WIN.
A WIN FOR MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
WHO ARE TRYING TO TRANSFER TITLE
INTO THEIR NAME.
IN A WIN FOR THE STATE AND
COUNTIES.
WHO CONTINUE TO UPDATE THE
RECORDS SO THAT TAXES AND FEES --
CAN BE COLLECTED FROM THE PROPER
INDIVIDUALS.
IT IS DEVASTATING WHEN A PERSON
DISCOVERS THAT A TITLE CANNOT BE
TRANSFERRED.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE MOBILE HOME
HAS BEEN PAID OFF. FOR MANY
RESIDENTS IT WILL BE THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY TO OWN A HOME.
THE DEPARTMENT.
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DATA.
SHOWS EXISTING PROGRAM HAS
ASSISTED OVER TWO THOUSAND
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS.
END QUOTE.
STEADY INCREASE MONTH OVER MONTH
IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
GS SO MORRELL SUPPORTS A. B..
ONE SEVEN THREE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS BRUCE STANTON OF THE
CORPORATE COUNSEL FOR GSM A WELL
THE SAME ORGANIZATION THAT
MISTER.
A JOHNSON JUST SPOKE ABOUT THIS
IS BEEN A VERY SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM THAT AFFECTS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MANUFACTURED MOBILE
HOMES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
IN FACT IF YOU GO TO DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING THEY HAVE ONE ROOM.
AND ALL FOUR WALLS ARE THE CUBBY
HOLES WITH THE BASKETS OF THESE
DEFECTIVE TITLES AND THEY HAVE
NO WAY OF KNOWING HOW TO CONTACT
THESE PEOPLE.
OR HOW TO REMEDY THE PROBLEM SO
THIS BILL WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
STARTING US DOWN THAT PATH.
THE ISSUES ARE CAUSED BY NO
ESCROW BEING USED STALE LENDERS
BEING ON TITLE THAT DON'T EXIST
ANYMORE AND NOBODY KNEW FOR
YEARS HOW TO REMOVE THOSE LEGAL
OWNERS FROM TITLE -- OR SALES
JUST OUTRIGHT SALES WITH BAD
TITLE THE RESULTS ARE HOMEOWNERS
OR WHO ARE AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR HOMES POSSIBLY BEING
TERMINATED IF PARK OWNERS --
WERE TO USE THAT TO SAY YOU'RE
NOT.
A PROPER TITLE HOLDER SO YOU
CAN'T STAY IN THE PARK AND AND
IN MANY CASES NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET PERMITS FROM H. C. D. TO DO.
NECESSARY REPAIRS IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S TWO WAYS OF REGISTERING
HOMES I. L. T. AND L. P. T..
I. L. T. IS IN LIEU OF TAX WHICH
IS PAID BY A REGISTRATION FEE TO
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING H. C. D..
L. P. T. IS LOCAL PROPERTY TAX
PAID TO THE COUNTIES.
THE BREAKDOWN IS APPROXIMATELY
60% OF THE HOMES ON I. L. T. AND
40% OF THE HOMES.
ON L. P. T. ACCORDING TO H. C.
D..
SO AS WE LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENED
IN THESE FIRST THREE YEARS WE
CAN SEE THE PROBLEM HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
AT THE L. P. T. LEVEL WE HAVE
THIRTY EIGHT OF FIFTY TWO
COUNTIES REPORTING SUCCESSFUL
APPLICATIONS. TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR OF THE EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED A SUCCESSFUL
APPLICATIONS WERE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
IN DOLLAR SAVINGS 15% OF THE
APPLICATIONS THAT COUNTY LEVEL
RESULTED IN 62% OF THE COST
SAVINGS.
SO THE L. P. T. IS ACTUALLY HAVE
YOUR WAITED IN TERMS OF THE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS -- SO I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW VERY IMPORTANT
WE'VE WE'VE ASSISTED AS MUCH AS
WE CAN WITH THE PENETRATION AND
THE OUT REACH OF THE PROGRAM.
HAVING MORE USED TO DO THAT I
THINK WOULD EVEN ACCELERATE THE
SUCCESS ESPECIALLY WITH MINORITY.
UNITY IS WHERE FOLKS NOT
UNDERSTANDING ENGLISH FOR HAVING
MORE TROUBLE UNDERSTANDING THE
ISSUE.
I WOULD JUST CLOSE BY SAYING
THAT SMALL IS NOT A PRINCIPLE
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD USE TO
EXCLUDE MINORITIES OF ANY SIZE
FROM EQUAL PROTECTION.
AND THAT'S ONE OF OUR LARGEST
CONCERNS HI HERE WITH THE
PROGRAM AS IT RELATES TO THIS
VALUABLE PIECE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SO WE WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
BY BRIAN A GUEST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
ANIME NOW ASK IF THERE IS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEN NONE LET AS BRINGS
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE LET ME
FIRST FOR FOR MISTER -- MISTER
CHAI I ASSUME YOU ARE AGREEING
TO THE MOMENTS YES RIGHT.
AND I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY TO
ADDRESS WHAT IS.
CHALLENGING MANY OF OUR
MARGINALIZED AND LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND BUILDING SOME
REAL ASSETS AND I THINK WHILE
ALL OF US WERE DISAPPOINTED IN
THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF THE
PROGRAM THAT WE DIDN'T SEE
GREATER UP TECH -- WE ARE ALL
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL HAVE MORE
FOLKS THAT USES PROGRAM INTO THE
COMING YEARS.
I DO WANT TO KNOW AT THE END OF
THE NEXT THREE YEARS I DO THINK
IF WE DO NOT SEE GREATER
SUCCESSES OBVIOUSLY WE PROBABLY
NEED.
TO TAKE A STEP BACK AND THINK
ABOUT GREATER OVERSIGHT OR OTHER
APPROACHES BUT I THINK CERTAINLY
IT IS WORTH US -- MOVING THIS
FOR FOR ANOTHER THREE YEARS LET
ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COLLEAGUES.
NOW.
OKAY THERE'S BEEN A MOTION IS
OUR SECOND.
ANY FINAL COMMENTS YOU LIKE TO
MAKE.
I JUST LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR LISTENING AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FARRAGO.
AND WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTIONS TO PRICES AMENDED IN
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CHIU HI CHIU I GAVE HI I
GABRIELLE.
GET REAL I GLORIA.
KILEY.
LEE MON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN I WORK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
YOUR BILL IS OUT WE WILL WAIT TO
ADD ON ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE.
LET'S GO NOW TO FILE ITEM SIX
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN MISS
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TODAY TO
PRESENT AB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
WHICH CREATES A NARROW EXEMPTION
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY. TO SELL DEED
RESTRICTED LAND TO ELIGIBLE LOW
INCOME HOMEOWNERS HOMEOWNERS AND
PROVIDES THE NEXT TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY HOME OWNERSHIP TO
THOSE IN NEED UNNECESSARY
HOUSING TO THOSE IN NEED.
DUE TO THE LIMITED AVAILABILITY
OF LAND PARTICULARLY IN COASTAL
COMMUNITIES LAND COSTS OF
REACHING ALL TIME HIGH.
THIS WILL BILL WOULD BETTER
UTILIZE SINGLE FAMILY LOTS BY
PROVIDING TWO HOMES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IN NEED ONE
BEING THE PRIMARY RESIDENCE AND
THE SECOND EIGHTY YOU ON THE
SAME PARCEL OF LAND.
NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS THE BEST WAY
FOR A FAMILY TO CREATE ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND TO BUILD ASSETS.
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS THE HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY HAS BEEN HELPING
LOW INCOME FAMILIES CLIMB THE
ECONOMIC LADDER AND TO CREATE
STABILITY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. EIGHTY
USE HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
LEGISLATURE'S IMPORTANT PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE TO SOLVING
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS.
STATE A LAW STATE LAW ALLOWS
JURISDICTIONS TO CREATE THEIR
OWN EIGHTY YOU ORDINANCES
SUBJECT TO CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS
OR IF NO LOCAL ORDINANCE EXISTS
TO APPROVE UP.
TO THE APPROVAL OF EIGHTY YOU
SUBJECT TO STATE STATUTE.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW PREVENTS A
SINGLE FAMILY LOTS FROM BEING
SUBDIVIDED SO YOU CAN'T KERR
UNDER CURRENT LAW SO THAT EIGHTY
YOU SEPARATELY FROM THE HOUSE.
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY MONTEREY
BAY HIS WORK WITH THE CITY OF
SANTA CRUZ SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE TO BUILD EIGHTY USER OWNER
OCCUPIED STRUCTURE THAT.
STRUCTURE THE OWNERSHIP OF THE
LAND IS HELD JOINTLY BY THE TO
HOMEOWNERS SUCH AS TENANTS IN
COMMON -- TI SEES AND I WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THIS PROGRAM
THAT WE SEEK TO ESTABLISH
STATEWIDE IS AN OFTEN FOR
COMMUNITIES WERE NOT FORCING
COMMUNITIES TO DO THIS WE WANT
TO MAKE IT AN OPTION WHICH RIGHT
NOW DOESN'T REALLY EXIST UNDER
STATE LAW.
I'M AB TWO FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
CODE OF FIRES THIS PROGRAM WITH
A SPECIFIC EXEMPTION FOR
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY IN ORDER TO SERVE TWICE
AS MANY FAMILIES ON THE SINGLE
LOCKS THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE
ACCESS.
TO IN THE MIDST OF OUR HOUSING
CRISIS CALIFORNIA HAS TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO HOUSE.
THOSE IN NEED -- WHO?
COULD WHO NEED A HOME AND THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE HABITAT CAN CONTINUE TO
BUILD AND CREATE STABILITY FOR
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE WELL
OPENING UP NEW OPTIONS FOR HOME
OWNERSHIP THAT DOESN'T EXST
RIGHT NOW WITH THE CURRENT
EIGHTY YOU -- ORDINANCES WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
RICARDO DELA CRUZ OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY FROM SANTA CRUZ TO
MONTEREY BAY AND JOHN LYNN HART
FROM HABITAT FOR HUMANITY OF YOU
COUNTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ITEM.
WELL LET ME START BY THANKING
YOU. FOR INVITING US.
AND I'M AND DO THIS QUICKLY BUT
OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU GET INTO THE
SUBJECT WE HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
INFORMATION WE ALWAYS WANT TO
SHARE -- OUR HABITAT -- WHICH
SHOW.
PRIMARILY REPRESENTS SANTA CRUZ
AND WE'RE OPENING UP MORE
ACTIVITY AND MONTEREY COUNTY
THOSE OF YOU MAY KNOW IS A
FAIRLY LARGE PLACE.
THAT ONE AND WE HAVE A MONTEREY
IN THE OTHER AND WE HAVE KING
CITY AND WE HAVE MANY MANY
HOUSING TYPE ISSUES.
SO.
BY A OUT PURSUING -- THIS BILL
PERFECTLY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN YOU
ACTUALLY ARE OFFERING US A
BETTER WAY OF DELIVERING A
PRODUCT -- IF WE IMAGINE NOW
BORE BUILDING NEW CONSTRUCTION A
NEW HOME.
AND THEN WERE ABLE -- TO AND A
SMALL UNIT WHERE TWO DIFFERENT
BUYERS CAN SHARE THAT PARCEL.
WE ARE AS A AS A NONPROFIT OR
ABLE.
TO PRODUCE. TWO HOUSES FOR TWO
DIFFERENT FAMILY TYPES ON THE
SAME PARCEL.
ARE ON NEW CONCERN OUR SENIORS
WE'RE LEARNING MORE MORE LEASE
ON THE COASTLINE.
DATA MANY ARE BECOMING C<c.cyan> AS</c>
A HOMELESS.
AND FOR WHATEVER REASON --
THEY'RE STRUGGLING AND RENTALS
AND TO HAVE THIS AVAILABLE TO
THEM OR A NEW FAMILY A YOUNG
FAMILY A SMALL FAMILY.
AGAIN OPENS UP TERRIFIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US -- IN IN
SUMMARY I WANT TO SUGGEST THAT
WERE WORKING CLOSELY NOW WITH
SEASIDE THE MERCI SITE --
SEASIDE DEL REY OAKS MARINA AND
ST CITY OR CITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE GOVERNOR AS
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED TO PROVIDE.
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I AND THIS WOULD BE ONE WAY.
WHERE WE AGAIN CAN PROVIDE
PROVIDE TWO QUICK PRODUCTS --
FOR THE EFFORT.
TO ONE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY -- MONEY JOHN ONE HARD ON
FROM CHICO AND REPRESENTING
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY BUTTE
COUNTY.
ON IN ADDITION TO EVERYTHING
RICK'S BEEN SAYING -- WE HAVE A
UNIQUE PROBLEM IN THE CHICO AREA
IN THE BUTTE COUNTY AREA.
IN THAT WE JUST EXPERIENCE THE
CAMPFIRE.
AND SO WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF OUR POPULATION IN THE
COUNTY THAT HAS BEEN DISPLACED --
PARADISE IS HAS BEEN
PREDOMINATELY A RETIREMENT
COMMUNITY.
AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN NOTICING IS
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF SENIORS
THAT HAVE LOST THEIR HOUSING AND
HAVE.
PROBABLY NO REAL OPPORTUNITY IN
THE CURRENT MARKET. TO GET A NEW
HOUSE OF CURRENTLY IN CHICO WE
HAVE THREE LOTS THAT WERE
GETTING READY TO START BUILDING
ON AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE THIS --
NEW LAW COMING INTO PLACE SO
THAT WE CAN OFFER NOT ONLY.
THREE FAMILIES IN CHICO BUT ALSO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE -- THREE
ADDITIONAL DWELLING UNITS -- FOR
PARADISE SENIORS.
ON THIS WOULD BE AN IDEAL
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE A
SMALLER FAMILY.
EITHER ONE OR TWO INDIVIDUALS.
THAT -- WE CAN PLACE IN AN
EIGHTY YOU IT DOESN'T END UP
IMPACTING OUR OUR CURRENT LAND
INVENTORY WHICH IS VIRTUALLY.
ZERO AND WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
REALLY SERVE BOTH COMMUNITIES
VERY WELL -- IT'S JUST IT MAKES
SENSE FOR US I THINK IT WOULD
PROVIDE A GREAT SERVICE TO THOSE
PEOPLE WHO UNFORTUNATELY.
HAVE NO PLACE ELSE TO GO AND WE
WOULD BE ABLE -- TO GET THEM
INTO HOUSING -- AND BE ABLE TO
TRANSFER OWNERSHIP SHOULD THIS
PASS.
ON IN A IN A LEGAL AND FAIR WAY.
SO WITH THAT I THANK YOU FOR ANY
CONSIDERATION AND I HOPE THAT --
YOU CAN CHECK FOR TO A IN THIS
ORDINANCE.
THANK YOU AND IF I COULD JUST
ADD ONE OTHER MODEL THAT WOULD
EXIST UNDER THIS BILL IS THAT
UGH.
ALL OF FIVE NONPROFIT LIKE
HABITAT OR ANOTHER COULD SELL
DIFFERENT UNIT AND RETAIN
OWNERSHIP OF THE REAR UNIT AND
THEN USE IT IS A LOW INCOME
RENTAL OR A MUNICIPALITY ITSELF
THERE HOUSING AUTHORITY WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THE SAME
THING.
SO THERE IS FLEXIBILITY BUILT IN
THAT -- YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW
DOESN'T EXIST UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THIS WORKS OF FIRST OF ALL TO
THE AUTHOR I REALLY.
LIKE THIS BILL SO I'D LIKE TO BE --
ADDED ON AS A JOINT AUTHORED --
BUT THIS IS THE KIND OF POLICY
THAT I THINK IN THE CRISIS THAT
WE ARE IN NOW SHOWS NOT ONLY --
CREATIVITY BUT ALSO LOOKING AT
EXISTING LAND AND WORKING WITH
TRUSTED PARTNERS LIKE HABITAT --
SO WITH THAT I MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU WOULD BE A LOT OF
HONOR TAX ID WAS A CO AUTHOR.
JOINT.
JOINT AUTHORED.
AND WITH THAT LET ME ASK IF
THERE ARE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT SUPPORT THE BILL.
TONY WITH CALIFORNIA PROPOSITION
HERE SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SAYS THE MATTER NOT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
AND ARE THERE ANY POINT TO THE
BILL.
OKAY SEEN IT NOW BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION.
I WANT TO THANK MS FREEMAN --
FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD I THINK
ALL OF US ARE BIG SUPPORTERS
WHAT HABITAT FOR HUMANITY HAVE
BEEN DOING AND I THINK IN RECENT
YEARS THE PUBLIC KNOWS THAT
WE'VE ALSO BEEN VERY FOCUSED AND
HOW WE EXPAND AN INCREASE EIGHTY
YOU PRODUCTION.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY SMART WAY
OF MARION A NUMBER OF VERY GOOD
THINGS AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL IN COMMITTEE TODAY AND WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND I
THINK DID I HEAR SECOND -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHU.
CHU I DATE HI I GABRIELLE
GABRIEL I GLORIA [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK SILVA.
GIVEN A BILL TOGETHER THAT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER ADD
ONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
LET'S MOVE TO LINE ITEM FOR AB
THREE THREE EIGHT MR CHIU --
RIGHT THANK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TIME MEMBERS ARE.
A FIRST WANT TO THANK YOU TO
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF. FOR
ALL YOUR WORKS ON TO BAIL AND BE
HAPPY TO A SAPPY COMMITTEES
AMENDMENT.
AB THREE THREE AID TO UPDATE THE
EXISTING SMOKE DETECTORS STATE
STANDARD.
BY REQUIRING A LISTED STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S SMOKE DETECTOR BE OF
THE PRESENT UPON LEASING OR SELL
OFF THE MOBILE HOME.
AND SECOND PART IS A UPON THE
UNDER THE EXISTING LAW.
PART OWNERS AND OPERATORS MUST
DEVELOP AND MAKE ASSESSABLE A
PARK EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLAN.
AB THREE THREE A BILL ON THOSE
REQUIREMENTS -- FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
WILL LEAD REQUIRED HIM TO
TRANSLATE THIS EXISTING
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLAN.
INCLUDING AN EVALUATION MAP AT
EVACUATION MAP A COMMUNITY
EMERGENCY SIGNALS. TO LOOK FOR
AND TO COMMON DISASTER IN THE
AREA.
AB THREE THREE AID REQUIRED PARK
OWNERS TO ME -- TO MAKE THESE
MULTI LINGUAL PLANS ASSESSABLE
WAS FOR THE ENGLISH VERSION AND
NOTIFIED RESIDENTS ANNUALLY HOW
TO ASSESS THERE'S CRITICAL
EMERGENCY INFORMATION.
IN THEIR OWN OF SPOKEN LANGUAGE.
IN THEM I THINK IT DOES BILLS
NECESSARY BECAUSE OF THE
STRUCTURE OF THE MOBILE HOME
PARK.
AND TO OF THAT TO VERY
DISTRAUGHT STRUCTURAL THE MOBILE
HOME -- ITSELF AND AND BE AT THE
VERY VERY TIGHT TO THE SPACE.
A AND A MOBILE HOME PARK SO IT
MAKES A ANY OF THEM [inaudible]
FIRED EMERGENCY -- OF WHAT WILL
WE ALSO.
VERY EASILY TO LOS HOOD TO
PROPERTY AS WELL AS THOSE LIVES
IN IN SAN JOSE -- OF DID THAT
THAT'S DEFINITELY TRUE
THEMSELVES A EVERY TIME WE HAVE
A MOBILE HOME FIRE WE LOS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND AROUND AND IN THE REASON TWO
FIRES UNDER -- TILL SO --
MEMBERS ARE ALL OF I'VE BEEN
MEANS AMERICANS -- SO THERE'S A
CONCERN ABOUT TWO LANGUAGES
SOUTH ABILITY IN TODAY REALLY
UNDERSTAND DO YOU EMERGENCY OF
EVACUATION PLAN TODAY REALLY
UNDERSTAND.
THE THE THE LOCAL EMERGENCY
SIGNALS TO LOOK FOR AND AND AND
AND IT.
GOOD COMMON DISASTER IN IN THIS
AREA SO THIS BILL WOULD IMPROVE
FIRE SAFETY.
AND PREPAREDNESS AND SAVE LIVES.
AB THREE THREE EIGHT IS
SPONSORED BY THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE.
AND ENJOYED TO SPAWN A TO
SUPPORT FROM THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS.
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
OF CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND GOLDEN SCARY
GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURING HOME
OWNERS LEAGUE AND OTHERS WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY.
I'M IN SUPPORT I HAVE CELLS A
FIRE CHIEF ROBERSON IAN.
AND ROGER JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
G. S. ¯
RESIDENTS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
SAT CHIEF.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY
NAME IS ROBERT SERBIAN I AM THE
SAN JOSE FIRE DEPARTMENT FIRE
CHIEF I AM BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THREE EIGHT AND AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED -- THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE IS A BILL
SPONSOR -- THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- AND A SPECIAL
THANK YOU TO OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU FOR RECOGNIZING THE
NEED FOR FIRE SAFETY.
IN OUR MOBILE HOME AND
MANUFACTURE HOME COMMUNITIES AND
FOR TAKING ACTION.
BY ADVANCING ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE THREE EIGHT ON AUGUST
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT
TWELVE THIRTY THREE PM SOUNDS A
FIRE DEPARTMENT RESOURCES WERE
DISPATCHED TO THE GOLDEN WILL
MOBILE HOME PARK.
IN SAN JOSE.
THIS WAS FOR A REPORTED FIRE.
UPON ARRIVAL OUR FIREFIGHTERS
FOUND A FULLY INVOLVED MOBILE
HOME THREATENING [inaudible]
NEIGHBORING HOMES.
ONCE FIREFIGHTERS WERE ABLE TO
STOP FIRE SPREAD THEY FOCUS
THEIR EFFORTS ON THE AGAIN FULLY
INVOLVED.
MOBILE HOME.
IT'S INTO THEIR FIRE ATTACK THEY
WERE APPROACHED BY FAMILY
MEMBERS OF THAT RESIDENTS.
AND THEY WERE EXPRESSING CONCERN
THAT.
THREE ALL WERE UNACCOUNTED.
FOR AS THE FIRE.
WAS KNOCKED DOWN AND A THOROUGH
SEARCH WAS CONDUCTED OF WHAT
REMAINED OF THAT RESIDENCE -- WE
FOUND -- AND WERE ABLE TO
CONFIRM THREE FATALITIES.
THIS WAS ONE SIXTY FOUR YEAR OLD
MALE. ONE TEN YEAR OLD FEMALE.
AND HER NINE YEAR OLD FEMALE
FRIEND WHO WAS VISITING THE HOME.
A THOROUGH INVESTIGATION COULD
NOT CONFIRM THE PRESENCE OF A
FUNCTIONING SMOKE ALARM IN THIS
RESIDENTS.
THE LOSSES ON THAT DAY IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WERE OF COURSE TRAGIC.
NOT ONLY FOR THE FAMILY MEMBERS
BUT ALSO FOR RESPONDING
FIREFIGHTERS.
AND IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR THE
ENTIRE SENDS A COMMUNITY.
BUT IT WAS ALSO A CALL TO ACTION.
TO ENSURE THAT THIS TYPE OF LIFE
LOS DIDN'T OCCUR AGAIN.
SINCE THIS EVENT THE SENATE THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT HAS PARTNERED
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY AMERICAN
RED CROSS.
IN THEIR SOUND THE ALARM.
CAMPAIGN WHICH RIGHT NOW IS
FOCUSED ON INSTALLING SMOKE
ALARMS AT EVERY MOBILE HOME PARK
IN THE CITY OF SAN JOSE.
WERE RESIDENTS ARE WILLING TO
ALLOW US INTO THEIR HOMES TO DO
THAT.
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT ALSO APPLIED
AND WAS AWARDED FEMA GRANT
FUNDING TO PURCHASE.
SMOKE ALARMS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
[inaudible]
PROJECT.
THROUGH THIS PROCESS WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED SOME CHALLENGES
ALONG THE WAY.
SOME RESIDENTS ARE DIFFICULT TO
REACH -- THEY HAVE LONG WORK
HOURS.
SOME HAVE LANGUAGE BARRIERS SOME
HAVE DISTRUST OF GOVERNMENT.
SUMMER VERY NEW.
RESIDENTS OF OUR CITY AND OUR
COUNTRY [inaudible]
AND ON VERY FEW OCCASIONS BUT
BUT IN SOME OCCASIONS WE HAVE
UNCOOPERATIVE PARK MANAGERS.
THESE CHALLENGES NEED TO BE
OVERCOME -- TO INFORM ON SAFETY
FOR OUR MEMBERS -- FOR OUR
RESIDENTS.
AND TO ALLOW US TO CONTINUE OUR
SMOKE ALARM INSTALLATIONS --
WHAT WE'RE FINDING AND MANY OF
OUR OUR MOBILE HOME PARKS IS WE
HAVE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS?
ELDERLY AND CHILDREN.
WE SEE IN THESE HOMES VERY RAPID
FIRE SPREAD BECAUSE OF THE LIGHT
WEEK BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
MATERIALS THAT ARE USED IN THESE
TYPE OF HOMES.
THESE HOMES HAVE LIMITED EGRESS
AND ACCESS POINTS -- AND THEY
ARE SMALL SPACES THAT FILLS WITH
SMOKE VERY RAPIDLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THREE EIGHT
PROVIDES US WITH TWO THINGS ONE
IS AT THE POINT OF TRANSACTION
IT ENSURES THAT THE WORK WE'VE
MADE PROGRESS ON TO INSTALL
SMOKE ALARMS.
IS CONTINUED TO THE NEXT OWNER
OCCUPANT OF THE STRUCTURE.
BUT IT ALSO HELPS US TO
PENETRATE.
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION FRONT --
AND ALLOW OUR NEWEST RESIDENTS
OFTEN ARE IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. TO BE INFORMED ON
HOW TO EXIT THEIR HOME SAFELY IN
THE EVENT OF A FIRE AND HOW TO
RESPOND TO OTHER EMERGENCIES.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY -- AND I PRAY
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
YES GOOD MORNING -- CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ROGER JOHNSON.
I'M A MEMBER OF IN REPRESENTING.
THE GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE G. -- SO MORAL.
GS A MORAL SUPPORT A. B..
THREE THREE EIGHT WHICH REQUIRES
UP TO DATE SMOKE ALARMS AND
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLANS.
WE WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU FOR RE INTRODUCING THIS
BILL.
N. DOT LAST YEAR THE STATE
EXPERIENCED MORE DEVASTATING
FIRES.
INCLUDING [inaudible]
OF THE DEVASTATION FROM THE
CAMPFIRE IN PARADISE.
WHERE MANYLIVES MOBILE HOMES
AND ENTIRE MOBILE HOME PARKS
WERE LOST?
WE CANNOT BE TOO PREPARED WHEN
IT COMES TO CALIFORNIA FIRES.
PROVIDING EMERGENCY MATERIALS IN
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
WILL HELP NEIGHBORS WHO DO NOT
SPEAK ENGLISH AS A FIRST
LANGUAGE PREPARE. FOR WHEN THE
NEXT DISASTER HITS.
THIS BILL WILL SAVE LIVES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
ON THIS IMPORTANT SAFETY ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT SUPPORT THE BILL.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS MADISON
DAHLIA BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
RED CROSS AND SUPPORT WE THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
I AM JEFF FLOCK FROM THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS TO THE BAY AREA CHAPTER WE
SUPPORT THIS WE THINK IT'S A
GREAT BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING STEVE CREWS ON
BEHALF OF SAN JOSE MAYOR SAM
LICCARDO IN SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE IS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME UP HERE SO --
POLISH I SOMEONE WHICH I DO THIS
CORRECTLY -- COMMITTEE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE -- THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK.
UP I LIKE TO LET YOU LOOK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MYSELF JUST SO
YOU UNDERSTAND MY BACKGROUND I'M
A MEMBER OF W. MAY WESTERN
MANUFACTURED.
COMMITTEES ASSOCIATION -- I
CURRENTLY SIT ON THEIR
LEGISLATURE -- COMMITTEE AND
ALSO ON THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
I HAVE BEEN IN THIS MANUFACTURED
HOUSING I CALLED THE MOBILE HOME
PARK INDUSTRY.
FOR CLOSE TO TWENTY YEARS I HAVE
A DEGREE.
FROM CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE --
BACHELORS OF ARTS IN DEAF
STUDIES WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
HUMAN SERVICES.
AND DURING MY EXPERIENCE THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS -- I'VE
OPERATED PARKS FROM IN.
OH SEVEN HARRIS FIRES THAT WERE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NEAR THE
SAN DIEGO.
AREA -- I'VE HAD PARKS OPERATING
IN THE SAN JOSE A COUPLE YEARS
BACK WHEN WE HAD THE FLOODS --
WE HAD A PROPERTY THAT -- HAD
DAMAGE -- FROM THE SANTA ROSA
FIRES AND ALSO YOU KNOW WENT
THROUGH THE AMERICAN CANYON
EARTHQUAKES.
I ALSO AM A SURVIVOR OF THE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE MINE WAS THE BUILDING
THAT COLLAPSED.
SO IS THE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
AND EDUCATION IS SOMETHING THAT
IS IS FUNDAMENTAL TO ME I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY IN HERE
DIMINISHES THE IMPORTANCE.
OF THE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF RECENT
EVENTS JUST THE ONES THAT I'VE
MENTIONED -- THE PARADISE FIRE
SO.
MY COMMENTS ARE NOT TO DIMINISH
THE IMPORTANCE OF HUMAN LIFE.
AND AS THE BILL STANDS.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE SMOKE
ALARMSI THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA
I THINK THAT THE LANGUAGE COULD
USE SOME FINE TUNING.
BUT IN GENERAL THE VALUE OF
HUMAN LIFE YOU KNOW WHAT TO HAVE
SMOKE DETECTORS I THINK IT'S
IT'S A GREAT IDEA.
WHERE I HAVE SOME CONCERNS AND
AGAIN IT IS ALWAYS DIFFICULT TO
TO VOICE SOME CONCERN ESPECIALLY
SINCE PEOPLE PUT SUCH GREAT
EFFORT AND WORK INTO MAKING A
BETTER PRODUCT?
IS AS IT COMES.
TO THE ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
THIS CURRENT BILL THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED MAKES ANY REAL CHANGE
IN THE OUTCOME AND THE REASON I
SAY THIS IS BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE HINDSIGHT
OBVIOUSLY EVERYBODY AGREES THE
PARADISE FIRES WERE TERRIBLE THE
SANTA ROSA FIRES WHICH I'M GOING.
TO USE MORE AS AN EXAMPLE
BECAUSE WE HAD PARKS WE WERE
OPERATING AT THAT TIME IN THAT
AREA.
GIVES US HINDSIGHT WE KNOW THAT
WHEN THE FIRE WAS NEAR THAT
LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENT CAME IN.
AND THEY DID BASICALLY WHAT I
CALL A SOFT WARNING YOU KNOW
WHAT WE RECOMMENDED THAT YOU
EVACUATE WE DO ALSO KNOW THAT
SHORTLY THEREAFTER THE WINDS
TOOK A HORRIBLE TURN.
AND THE FIRE PRETTY MUCH PUT
SANTA ROSA ON FIRE AT THAT TIME
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL.
WHAT IT WAS A FIRE DEPARTMENT
POLICE DEPARTMENT WHOEVER WAS
AVAILABLE WENT THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY AND BASICALLY SET GET
OUT?
YOU HAVE TO EVACUATE NOW THE
FIRE IS COMING.
AND WE CAN'T STOP IT.
THAT WAS DONE IN ENGLISH
EVERYBODY UNDERSTOOD THAT AND
THEY GOT OUT I'D LIKE TO STRESS
ALSO THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN
PLACE.
WHICH WAS BASED OFF OF THE
PREVIOUS BILL.
NUMBER TWO PREPARE TO SLANT IN
PLACE IT'S A FORTY TWO ALL
RESIDENTS AT ANY TIME WHEN THEY
WANT THEY WANTED BUT IT'S ALSO
AFFORDED ANNUALLY.
IT'S POSTED IN THE COMMUNITY
SOMEWHERE VISIBLE THAT THEY CAN
GET TO IT ANY TIMES IT'S NOT
LOCKED AWAY IN AN OFFICE IT'S
ALWAYS READILY AVAILABLE.
SO WE HAVE THE HEINZ LIKE TO
TAKE A LOOK BACK AND SAY WHAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE WORKED.
MY CONCERNED WITH THE ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGES IN AGAIN IT TAKES US
AWAY FROM THE THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLAN IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND TRANSLATE
IT NOW.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
BACK AND FORTH AS FAR WELL WHAT
WE MAY JUST HAVE A CERTAIN
PORTION TRANSLATED THAT'S MORE
UNIFORM.
THERE WHILE PROXIMATE LEE WHAT
FORTY ONE HUNDRED MOBILE HOME
PARKS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
CHANCES ARE YOU HAVE FORTY ONE
HUNDRED EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PLANS.
EVERY PARK OPERATOR.
HAS THE BASIS OF WHAT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE USED BUT SOME LIKE THE
COMPANY I WORK.
FOR PROVIDE A LOT MORE
INFORMATION SO OUR DOCKING COULD
BE FORTY FIVE TO FIFTY FIVE
PAGES LONG.
WE PROVIDE EVERYTHING IN ENGLISH
ENGLISH IS THE PURPOSE FOR THAT
IS BECAUSE I CAN WRITE SOMETHING
UP AND I COULD TELL YOU WHAT MY
INTENT AND WHAT IT MEANS.
THE MORE MOVIES ARE GOING TO
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
A PERSON LIVING IN A COMMUNITY
COULD REASONABLY EXPECT WHY ARE
WE STOPPING HERE WHY ARE YOU
THAT PROVIDING ALL THESE OTHER.
DOCUMENTS IN THAT LANGUAGE.
THAT THAT IS A VERY BIG CONCERN
FOR US THAT IT'S A VALID POINT
THAT COULD BE MADE IT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WE DON'T DO.
WE HAVE FOR THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE ANY OF OUR DOCUMENTS AND
HAVE BEEN TRANSLATED ON THEIR
OWN BUT WE DON'T WANT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY OR LIABILITY.
OF IT -- I'VE I HAVE ANOTHER
CONCERN AS TO HOW EXACTLY IS
THIS GOING TO BE MANAGED
OBVIOUSLY THE STATE TAKING THE
RESPONSIBILITY IS A GREAT.
BUT AS I UNDERSTAND EIGHT CD
WOULD BE ACCEPTING THIS ROLE WE
JUST HAD A BILL THAT WAS BEING
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
WHERE WE UNDERSTAND EIGHTY HAS A
VERY DIFFICULT JOB TO DO THEY
HAVE A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITIES
AND WHENEVER SOMETHING NEW IS
CREATED IT'S KIND OF COOL WOULD
JUST GIVE IT TO A CD?
I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF THE
MEMBERS HERE HAVE EVER TRIED TO
CALL EIGHT CD OR DO A TITLE
TRANSFER THOSE THINGS TAKE A
VERY LONG TIME SO.
IN GENERAL I HAVE.
A LOT OF CONCERN AS TO THE
TRANSLATION PROCESS IF IT'S ONLY
A PORTION.
IT IS VERY REASONABLE TO EXPECT
THAT A MEMBER OF OUR COMMITTEE
COME BACK AND SAY WELL.
WHY ARE YOU ONLY TRANSLATING
THIS PORTION FOR US WHY ARE YOU
NOT TRANSLATING THE REST OF THE
DOCUMENT?
I I SPEAK SPANISH I CAN READ
SPANISH BUT IF SOMEONE SENT ME A
DOCUMENT ASSISTED WE GOT THIS
TRANSLATED FOR YOU AND IT'S IN
VIETNAMESE.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
WHETHER THAT'S BEING DONE
CORRECTLY BUT I DO KNOW THAT AS
AN OPERATOR WE'RE GONNA BE HELD
TO A BAR.
THIS SAYS EVERYTHING THAT'S HERE.
YES FROM THE PARK IT'S BEEN
REPRESENTED AS WHAT IT IS SO IT
PRESENTS A LOGISTICAL ISSUES
JUST IN.
GENERAL THE OTHER CONCERN I HAVE
IN READING THE BILL IS.
IT'S ONLY LIMITED TO OUR
INDUSTRY MOBILE HOME PARKS.
AND I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AS
A LAYPERSON I'M NOT A LOBBYIST
I'M JUST A LAY PERSON.
WHAT MAKES OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS?
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW IDEAS
ORIGINAL INTENT IN HIS SB TWENTY
THREE WAS TO PROVIDE EVACUATION
ROUTES PROVIDE BASIC EMERGENCY.
INFORMATION BUT IT WAS NEVER HIS
INTENT TO CREATE A
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PHYSICAL
EVACUATION.
AND EMPHASIZED [inaudible]
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
IT BY TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY ARE
BEING VIEWED DIFFERENTLY THAT
THERE CAN'T.
MANAGE THESE THINGS ON THEIR OWN
AS IT STANDS AS WE ALREADY
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION SO I
FIND A LITTLE DISCONCERTING THAT.
APARTMENT THE CONDOMINIUMS AND
SO FORTH ONE INCLUDED IN THAT.
BUT WITH THAT SAID -- THAT'S ALL
I HAVE TO SAY IN APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SPEAKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET ME ASK
IF THERE ARE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
LET'S BRING IT BACK FOR
COMMITTEE DISCUSSION COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
MR BUSTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
THIS IS GERMAN I I'M READING
YOUR AT YOUR ANALYSIS HERE ON
THIS BILL AND AND AND I WANT TO
SAY THAT -- COMING FROM.
A A COMING FROM A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ABOUT BACKGROUND WITH
MANY MANY A MOBILE HOME -- PARKS --
IN IN IN IN.
IN MY CITY AND THEN ALSO IN IN
MY DISTRICT -- I AM VERY -- VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- CHOOSE DOING A WE HAD
THE SAME.
ISSUE IN NGUYEN WAS CENSORED
LAST YEAR WHEN IT COMES -- TO TO
LANGUAGE BERIA AND WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO WORK THAT OUT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
IT WAS JUST ONE CITY AND AND IF
YOU PARKS -- I DO WANNA AS
MISTER CHAIRMAN I I DO WHEN
ASKED.
IF THE THE AUTHOR WOULD CONSIDER --
A A SMALL AMENDMENT BECAUSE IN
IN HIS BILL.
OF IF IF PASS OR SIGN TO LAW
WOULD REQUIRE -- EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLAN TO BE
TRANSLATED.
IN LANGUAGES THAT MEETS THE MEDI
CAL -- DRESSEL BUT ALSO -- IN
ANY LANGUAGE THAT.
IS REQUEST EVEN BY ONE RESIDENT --
WE WE HAVE.
WE WE WE KNOW THERE'S MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT.
WE IS THE STATE PROVIDES A
TRANSLATION TO INCLUDING BEANIES
ARE DOLLAR BECAUSE SPANISH.
MANDARIN KOREANS AND AND SO ON
SO ON AND I THINK ALL THOSE
LANGUAGES.
MEETTHE MEDI CAL TO WRESTLE BUT
IF IF IF YOUR BILL AS AS WRITTEN.
IF THERE'S JUST. ONE ONE ONE ONE
TENANT.
THAT SPEAKS OF A VERY -- THAT
THAT THE SIX THE LET LANGUAGE
THAT.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE.
USED THE THAT I CAN SEE HOW THAT
WOULD PUT.
A LOT OF BURDEN ON ON THE PARK
OWNER IF THIS IF IT'S JUST ONE
TEN AND REQUIRING. ONE ONE
LANGUAGE SOUL MISTER CHAIRMAN I
I DON'T KNOW IF IF THE AUTHOR
WOULD CONSIDER -- TIGHTEN THAT
UP A LITTLE BIT SO THAT. ONE
PERSON CAN'T JUST COME IN THERE
AND SAID HEY.
HELLO I MEAN I I DON'T WANT TO
THROW IT A A RANDOM LANGUAGE OUT
THERE -- TO THE TO TO SOUND MEAN
OR OR AND DISRESPECTFUL TO TO
THAT PARTICULAR.
OF CULTURE OR LANGUAGE BUT BUT
WOULD HE CONSIDER TIED THAT UP
WHERE WE DO HAVE A CUT OFF EDGES.
MEDI CAL IN WHICH TO ALL OF THE
AUTHOR IF YOU LIKE TO RESPOND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR AGREED WITH THE
LANGUAGES SAYS ABILITY IS VERY
IMPORTANT -- REGARDING.
TO YOUR ROOM US FOR MEDI CAL
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES OR JUST ONE
SINGLE REQUIRE US. TO BURDEN
WILL BE ON THE EACH CD US NOT TO
GO TO A PARK OPERATOR.
SO DO A DAY CAN REQUIRE US TO A
SPEECH CD TO DO THE TRANSLATION.
AND THEN -- I'M POSTED ON ON
THEIR OWN TO WEBSITE OR YOU ARE
ARE -- MELDED TO DUMB AND AND
THEIR LANGUAGE.
SO.
AT THIS POINT -- I LIKE TO HAVE
A BROADER COVERAGE.
YOU KNOW -- MAYBE IN A FEW YEARS
SO WE DON'T HAVE WHAT DID THE H.
C. NEVER RECEIVE ANY REQUIRES.
AND WILL PROBABLY CAN NARROW
DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE THE MOBILE
HOME THE STRUCTURE LIKE THIS
CHIEF MENTION OF THE MOBILE HOME
AND THE TIGHT SPACE.
YOU KNOW THEY HELP IN THE MOBILE
HOME PARK.
WE WANTED TO REALLY.
PREVENT ANY.
FOR AS FIRES AND A MOBILE HOME
PARK AS POSSIBLE THIS BECAUSE
YOU CAN EASILY SPREAD TO YOUR
NEIGHBORS.
AND ALSO DATED TO THE TIED TO
**** IS IS BROUGH SOMETIME
BEFORE YOU DON'T.
KNOW THE EVACUATION PLAN IF YOU
DON'T KNOW DE IT THERE TO DO THE
EMERGENCY SIGNAL IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET OUT.
SO WE DON'T WANT TO EXCLUDE.
ANYBODY AT THIS POINT.
IT'S YOU KNOW LIKE I SAY DUE TO
FIRE CAN SPREAD BROUGH REAL
QUICKLY A PEN IT'LL CAN I
CLARIFY THAT WITH THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT IS.
IS THE IS A BURDEN ON ON THE ON
THE PARK OWNER OR ON ON THE
TENANT TO REQUEST -- THE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLAN.
IN IN IN IN A PARTICULAR
LANGUAGE.
OF WITH A CD AND OR OR OR LIKE
WHO LIKE WHO'S WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR FOR MAKING THAT.
THAT REQUEST AND THE CONTACT --
AS I READ THE BILL THAT THE
RESIN IS -- WOULD MAKE THE
REQUEST -- OF THE PARK OWNER.
AND THEN THEY WOULD MAKE THEIR
TERM MAKE I REQUEST A CD.
RIGHT.
YEAH AND AND AND AND AND AND I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S MY THAT'S
JUST MY SMALL CONCERT WITH THIS
BILL IS THAT IT.
IT WILL IT WILL PULL THE PARK
OWNER -- INTO.
SOMEWHAT OF A YOU KNOW LIKE A
LENGTHY PROCESS WE ALL KNOW THAT
A THE STATE BUREAUCRACY IS NOT
THE EASIEST OF PLACER THE A TO
WORK WITHIN.
THE LAST MY CONCERN THAT WE WE
WE WE DON'T HAVE WE DON'T HAVE A
A CUT OFF WRESTLE ANYWHERE IS IS
ANYBODY CAN COME IN WITH.
WITH A WITH A DIALECT THAT -- NO
ONE USE EXCEPT THAT PARTICULAR
ATTENDED AND THEN THE UNDER THIS
LAW.
THE OF THE THE PARK OWNER HAVE
TO PUT IN A REQUEST WITH THE
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT --
OR HOW THE COMMUNITY APARTMENT
JUST FOR JUST FOR THAT ONE PLAN
FILL OUT.
OF MY CONCERT WITH THIS BILL IT
OVERALL I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE IT.
IS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT IS
ACTUALLY IN GENERAL NEEDED.
IF I CAN -- THIS IS A
CONVERSATION THAT I'VE BEEN
HAVING WITH THE AUTHOR THIS BILL
FOR A COUPLE YEARS AND
COLLEAGUES YOU MAY REMEMBER WE
ACTUALLY VOTED TO PASS THIS BILL
OUT -- IT WENT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WAS AGREED
UPON BY THE LEGISLATURE WENT TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND WAS
VETOED -- IN PART OVER THESE
ISSUES I THINK WHAT WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON IS THE ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL THAT WOULD IMPROVE --
REQUIREMENTS AROUND SMOKE
DETECTORS OR SOMETHING I DON'T
THINK ANYONE DISPUTES AND I
THINK EVERYONE WOULD ALSO AGREE
THAT.
ENSURE LANGUAGE ACCESS IS
CRITICAL AND IMPORTANT -- I DO
KNOW THAT -- THE CONVERSATION
THAT THE AUTHORS HAVING WITH THE
OPPOSITION IS AROUND HOW TO DO
THAT MOST EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY I APPRECIATE THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN AMENDMENTS
THAT OUR COMMITTEE HAS SUGGESTED
TO HELP STREAMLINE THAT AND
ESSENTIALLY.
WHAT WE PROPOSED WAS FOR THE
COMMON ELEMENTS OF ALL OF THESE
EMERGENCY PLANS THAT THAT BE PRE
TRANSLATED SO THAT WE'RE NOT
REINVENTING THE WHEEL EVERY TIME --
BUT THE BILL DOES ALLOW FOR THE
CONTINUE TRANSLATION INTO THE
LANGUAGES THAT ARE REQUIRED OF
OTHER ASPECTS OF THAT AND I DO
KNOW THAT IS A ISSUE.
I THINK AS I DISCUSSED WITH THE
AUTHOR JUST YESTERDAY THIS IS A
TOPIC THAT I KNOW HE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND CONSIDER
THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT I DO
THINK AT THIS POINT -- THE
PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN MADE ON ON
THESE PROVISIONS -- WITH THE
AMENDMENTS MAKES SENSE FOR FOR
ME TO SUPPORT AND WITH THAT I
HAVE THAT RECOMMENDATION BUT THE
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION.
IF THERE ISN'T I WILL ASK THE
AUTHOR IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMITTEE LIKE TO MAKE.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE YOU ARE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I BOTH --
I'M I'M GLAD TO HEAR SOME OF THE
OF MOBILE HOME OWNERS OPERATORS --
A HOUSE A MORE EXTENSIVE POPE
[inaudible]
BOCA -- EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
FOR A A DOCUMENT.
AND THAT'S A GREAT INDICATION TO
SEE HOW IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE IS.
AND ALONE STRESS ON THE LANGUAGE
ASSESSABLE HE YOU CAN HOW.
YOU KNOW OF THIS MUCH HOPE
INFORMATION I MEAN FIFTY SIX
PAGES FOR FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
PAGES.
IF DO YOU PEOPLE THAT ON THE
RECEIVING END DOESN'T UNDERSTAND.
AWARD.
IN OLD TO MADE IS IS IS IS THIS
REALLY A TOTAL WASTE.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- NOT
JUST TO PROPERTY HERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HUMAN LIFE.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE MOBILE HOME
PARK.
IS IN SAN JOSE'S BY 25% OFF THE
TO THE TO THE OF THE EIGHT
APPLAUDED LOW INCOME HOUSING IN
THE TREES SO.
ATTACKING THOSE BARE RESUME OF
BONE WROBEL -- A GROUP OF OUR
COMMUNITY IT IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE'S
A MOTION TO MOVE THIS FORWARD.
HIS THEIR SECOND -- AND WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CHIU I CHIU I'D DIP HI I
GABRIELLE.
GABRIELLE I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
LIMóN MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
YOUR BILL IS OUT WE WILL WAIT
FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON WITH
THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET US GO TO OUR NEXT AUTHORED
BYE LED HIM TO AB FIFTY EIGHT MS
REMUS.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERING THIS --
AB FIFTY EIGHT WOULD ADD A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL.
ON LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE --
TASK THE HOMELESS AND
COORDINATING COUNCIL WITH THE
DRESSING YOUTH HOMELESSNESS IN
THE STATE AND ADDED TO THE
COUNCIL REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
AND A FORMERLY HOMELESS YOUTH
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA BUT DID NOT
INCLUDE OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
A BECAUSE SCHOOLS ARE OFTEN THE
FIRST ENTITIES TO IDENTIFY AND
ASSIST HOMELESS STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED.
UP TO HELP THE COUNCIL
ACCOMPLISH ITS MISSION ON THIS
BILL ENSURES THAT THE COUNCIL IS
ABLE TO UTILIZE ALL RESOURCES.
TO COME TO COMBAT YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS BY GIVING THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION A SEAT
AT THE TABLE.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
IN A MOTION MOVE A MOTION TO
SECOND ANY SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL.
BUT FORGET THE SMS OR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING THE COMPANY
COALITION FOR YEAR THAN
APPRECIATE THE ADDITION OF
EDUCATION BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY
HUGE FOR ADJUSTING HOMELESSNESS
THANK YOU.
AND ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR I KNOW
YOUR PERSONAL AND LONGSTANDING
COMMITMENT TO ENDING YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS AND APPRECIATE OUR
TOGETHER.
IN -- INSURING THAT WE ARE
TRACKING WHO IS ALMOST AMONG
YOUNGER POPULATIONS -- THROUGH
THE AUDIT THAT WE'VE REQUESTED --
AND LESTER'S FOR THE DISCUSSION
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO ADD AND
YOUR CLOTHES RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EYEBALLS.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
A TWO BY TWO I DEEP HI I EVERIO.
EVERIO I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY LIMóN.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
THANK YOU YOUR BILL IS OUT.
A COLLEAGUES WE DO NOT HAVE
QUORUM WHEN WE WERE DISCUSSING
FILE ITEM FIVE AB FOR ELEVEN MR
STONE LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
THAT WE MOVE THAT BILL FORWARD
AS AMENDED.
DO PASSED TO ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- WITHIN MINUTES WE
WITH THE MEMBERS TO BE TAKEN IN
THAT COMMITTEE MOTION BY MS
QUIRK SILVA SECOND BY.
MR GABRIEL MADAM SECRETARY --
MOTION TO PASS -- AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHIU
CHU I DATE NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
POURING GABRIELLE [inaudible]
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY [inaudible]
LEE MON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NINE
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
THAT BILLS OUT WILL WAIT FOR
ANNA MEMBERS AND THEN WE HAVE
ONE FINAL ITEM AND THAT IS MIND
WHICH IS FILE ITEM ONE A. B..
TEN AND IN TURN THE GAVEL OVER
TO OUR VICE CHAIR
.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF A YOU I MEAN
OPEN [inaudible]
FOR OPENING STATEMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB TEN WHICH
WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION
OF OUR STATES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TAX CREDIT -- I'LL JUST NOTE
THIS IS ACTUALLY THIS IS THE
VERY FIRST BILL I EVER
INTRODUCED WHEN I FIRST CAME TO
THE LEGISLATURE NOW FIVE YEARS
AGO.
IT IS THE ONLY BILL THAT I'VE
INTRODUCED EVERY YEAR -- AND I
WANT TO FIRST THANK ALL OF MOST
OF YOU HAVE VOTED FOR THIS THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AS
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS.
IT WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN
AND PART OF THE REASON WE'RE
BRINGING IT BACK WAS.
THEN CANDIDATE NOW GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM CAMPAIGNED ON THE
IDEA OF EXPANDING -- THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX CREDIT
AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO HIM
AND THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR PROPOSING THE EXACT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR EXPANSION
THAT WE ARE PROPOSING.
A AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COALITION THAT HAS BEEN WORKING
ON THIS -- TIRELESSLY FOR MANY
YEARS -- I DON'T NEED TO GO
THROUGH THE DETAILS OF THE
INTENSITY OF OUR HOUSING CRISIS
AND I THINK THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS
WELL.
HOW MUCH AFTER THE GREAT
RECESSION WE LOST IN STATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO THE TUNE
OF ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR WHEN PASSED BOND
MONIES DRIED UP?
I AND REDEVELOPMENT WENT AWAY.
THIS IS AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TAX CREDIT THAT HAS PROVEN TO BE
REMARKABLY.
EFFECTIVE OVER THE YEARS IT
LEVERAGES AT LEAST TWO TO ONE
DOLLAR SO AND EIGHT AND
INVESTMENT OF A NEW HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS WOULD RESULT IN
AN ADDITIONAL.
BILLION DOLLARS OF FEDERAL AND
LOCAL AND PRIVATE SECTOR FUNDING.
THIS IS A TAX CREDIT THAT IS
HIGHLY OVERSUBSCRIBED THE DEMAND
FROM OUR MANY DISTRICTS -- IS
VERY INTENSE AND AND THIS WOULD
HELP TO ADDRESS AT I WOULD ALSO
MENTION -- THAT WITH THE PASSAGE
OF THE RECENT -- TRUMP TAX PLAN
WHICH WE ALL KNOW REDUCED THE
CORPORATE TAX RATE FROM 35% 221%.
THAT HAS HAD A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON THE PRICE OF THIS TAX
CREDIT ONE ASPECT OF THIS BILL --
THAT WE HAVE ADDED IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS AFTER THAT TAX PLAN
CHANGE WAS TO ELIMINATE THE
CURRENT SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR CAP ON AN INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYERS OFFSET. FOR PASSIVE
RENTAL REAL ESTATE ACTIVITIES
WHAT THAT WILL ALLOW IS FOR THIS
TAX CREDIT TO ACTUALLY BE MORE
VALUABLE TO REALLY OFFSET THE
IMPACT SO WITH THAT A VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING TYRONE BUCKLEY WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IS THE NONPROFIT AD
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION FIGHTING
FOR THE MORE THAN ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIA FAMILIES WHO
ARE STRUGGLING.
THE MOST TO AFFORD OUR STATES --
INCREASINGLY EXPENSIVE RENTS --
WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL AGAIN -- AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS TIRELESS --
EFFORT TO GET THIS DONE HOUSING
PRICES ARE DRIVING COSTS OF
LIVING OUT OF REACH FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE AS
A RESULT ONE IN THREE HOUSEHOLDS
KONAMI BASIC NEEDS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT ACCORDING TO
LATEST REPORTS THAT DESPITE THE
PASSAGE OF RECENT LISTED
LEGISLATION IN BONDS.
STATE FUNNY TODAY REMAINS WELL
BELOW TO TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
LEVELS UNDERMINING PROGRESS AND
INJURIES ADDRESSING WHAT IS NOW
WELL RECOGNIZED AS A HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL -- TEN AS
MENTIONED WILL WILL EXPAND THE
TAXPAYER PROGRAM BY FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS -- WHICH
WE THINK IS KEY AND CORPS -- AS
AS AS A MEMBER CHU NOTED -- THE
IT'S A SMART PROPOSAL THAT
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC PRIVATE INVESTMENT -- BUT
TO AND TO SOLVE AND GET DEEPLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN
ADDITION -- THIS IS GOING TO
DRAW DOWN A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF FEDERAL FUNDS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FUNDS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY LEAVING ON THE TABLE
AND BEEN LEAVING ON THE TABLE
FOR YEARS.
SO -- HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
WE ARE DR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARIN
HIGGINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM.
THE STATE AND FEDERAL TAX
CREDITS ARE TO THE MOST
IMPORTANT HOUSING PRODUCTION
PROGRAMS WE HAVE BECAUSE THEY
FOR THEY ALLOW PRIVATE
INVESTMENT TO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED EQUITY IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS.
SO THIS BILL IN EXPANDING THE
AMOUNT OF THE CREDIT AND IN
MAKING IMPORTANT STATUTORY
CHANGES TO INCREASE THE VALUE OF
THE CREDIT WHEN IT'S PAIRED WITH.
4% OF FEDERAL TAX CREDIT AND TAX
EXEMPT BONDS BRINGS A A LARGE
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL SUBSIDY TO THE
TABLE FOR INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS -- MY
COLLEAGUE SAID HAS BEEN LEFT ON
THE TABLE IN THE PAST.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE VERY
HAPPY TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL
ENERGY RIVAL.
THANK YOU -- ANY SUPPORTERS OF
FOR THIS BILL JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT -- MICHAEL
RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
JANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF INTER
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
TONY WITH CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
SOLUTION HERE SUPPORT.
MY SECOND CELLS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
I KNOW OUR WITH THE RESTAURANTS
ARE AMONG POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
PATRICK OF ALL BEHALF WITH THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
I'M MARIE SUBRON OF THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
TEN BRIAN A GUEST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR RURAL
HOUSING AND SUPPORT.
MARYLAND SHEA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT
LET'S GET IT DONE THIS TIME.
LOUIS MONTANA HAVE OF CALIFORNIA
MEANS TRANSPORT.
LET'S HAVE A REPRESENTING THE
CAL ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY --
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
HEARING SEEING NONE -- IS
CHAIRMAN YOU MAY CLOSE.
I HOPE THIS LAST TIME I
PRESENTED FOR DISCONNECT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- GIVER.
I JUST WANTED -- TO IT'S THANK
OUR CHAIRMAN FOR HIS TENACITY
AND HIS LEADERSHIP I THINK THIS
IS -- IMPORTANT -- PROUD TO BE A
PRINCIPAL BECAUSE OF THIS BILL
AND JUST REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
CONTINUE TO PUSH THIS FORWARD
AND GLAD TO SEE THAT -- OUR NEW
GOVERNOR'S ALSO SUPPORTER OF IT
AND JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ANY OF SOME WOMEN GLORIA -- ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE MR
GABRIEL AND I'LL JUST ASK -- IN
TERMS OF THAT -- GREATER
CAPACITY THAT ARE GOVERNOR'S
SUPPORT OF OF WHICH I THINK IT'S
FANTASTIC AND THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION IN TERMS
OF THE INCOME THRESHOLD -- THAT
ARE CONSIDERED BY THE GOVERNOR
VERSES THIS BILL CAN YOU SPEAK
TO YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT WHY
YOU'RE GOING A DIFFERENT WAY
THAN WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S ASK.
FOR WELL THIS -- THIS IS A BILL
THAT WE ORIGINALLY HAD PROPOSED
IN DECEMBER BEFORE -- THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED HIS BUDGET
AND I THINK CERTAINLY THE NEED
UP AND DOWN THE INCOME SCALE IS --
IS IS VERY INTENSE AND WHAT
MISTER GORE IS REFERRING TO IS A
MISTER NEWSOME IN HIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL -- PROPOSE THAT A
PORTION OF THE TAX CREDIT -- BE
FOCUSED ON MORE MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING SO ABOVE LOW AND VERY
LOW AN EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS -- THE GOVERNOR
ACTUALLY IN HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
NOT ONLY PROPOSES MORE MODERATE
INCOME ASPECTS OF THE TAX CREDIT
BUT HE ALSO I THINK.
HAD ANOTHER HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS THAT HE PROPOSED THAT
ALSO GO TO MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING AND SO.
WE ARE HAVING DISCUSSIONS RIGHT
NOW ON EXACTLY WHAT ARE THE BEST
LOVERS TO USE BOTH TO ADDRESS
THE NEED.
AT LOWER INCOME LEVELS AS WELL
AS IN THE MODERATE INCOME SIDE --
AND THAT DISCUSSION IS ON GOING
SO I THINK FOR NOW WE LIKE THE
PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE AS IT IS
BUT WE'LL SEE HOW THIS INVOLVES --
IN THE COMING MONTHS.
I APPRECIATED OPEN THIS MEANS I
THINK OBVIOUSLY TAXPAYERS
SUBSIDY SHOULD GO TO THE LOWEST
INCOME PEOPLE WILL KNOW
PRESUMABLY HOPEFULLY -- OF FOLKS
WHO WORK FULL TIME DON'T NEED
PUBLIC SUBSIDY IN ORDER TO MAKE
ENDS MEET THAT'S NOT SO THE
REALITY IN CALIFORNIA TODAY --
I'M SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY I
HOPE THIS CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT -- MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING I CERTAINLY WHEN I GET
THE MOST -- FEEDBACK ABOUT IN
TERMS OF MY CONSTITUENCY -- AND
WHETHER THAT IS -- REGULATORY
REFORM OR OTHER THINGS OF THAT
SORT OF A PRIME THE PUMP UP THE
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING AGAIN
THAT'S NOT SUBSIDIZED I THINK
THAT'S PHILOSOPHICALLY WHY I
PREFER TO SEE.
I THINK THE REALITY IS THAT WE
INCREASINGLY SEE THE NEED TO
SUBSIDIZE UP 210020% YEAH I MEAN
INCOME.
AND THERE'S PROBABLY WATCH TWO
REASONS IT OR OF LONGER TERM
PLACES WE NEED DO IN THE SHORT
TERM -- YOU KNOW MAYBE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION AND APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS WILLINGNESS TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATIONS THE PORCINE
HARDENS UP -- AS WE BECAUSE OF
THE TALENTS THAT PROCESS THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU I'LL JUST
MENTION TWO OTHER THINGS.
WHEN IT COMES TO TRADITIONAL FOR
WHAT HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAMS --
FOR LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS --
THAT TAX MATCH IS THERE WHERE
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THERE --
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TRYING
TO MATCH THAT 1810020% A MIND SO --
THE DOLLARS THAT WE SPEND -- FOR
FOR THAT RANGE GOES FARTHER AND
SO THAT IS ANOTHER REASON WHY WE
WANTED TO MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION
BUT THAT BEING SAID.
I THINK THERE IS A VERY VALID
CONVERSATION WE NEED TO HAVE ON
THE SO CALLED MISSING MIDDLE --
YOU AND I ARE WORKING TOGETHER
ANOTHER BILL THAT WE WILL BE
PRESENTING IN THIS COMMITTEE --
TO HOPEFULLY MOVE FORWARD --
ADDITIONAL TAX RELIEF FOR
PRODUCTION THAT AREA I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING WE ABSOLUTE HAVE
TO TACKLE I AND THE FACT OF
MATTER IS THE CRISIS IS
IMPACTING ALL.
PARTS OF THE INCOME SPECTRUM AND
WE'VE GOT TO JUST FIGURE OUT HOW
TO BALANCE THE SMARTEST AND MOST
AFFECTED PROPOSALS IN EACH
CATEGORY.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
HEARING NONE OF IS THERE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOVE BY -- SOMEONE GABRIEL
SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA OF
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMEDIAN REVENUE AND
TAXATION.
DEEP.
YES.
I GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY I LIMóN.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I CHU.
CHU I KEEP THE A THE ROLE PLAN
FOR AT LINDEMANN HANDED BACK TO
A THIS IS GERMAN.
THANK YOU WANNA WE GO THROUGH
THE ROLE AND ADD ON ABSENT
MEMBERS -- MADAM SECRETARY ONE
WE START WITH FILE ITEM.
ONE THE MISSING MEMBERS.
ED -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE
MONTH.
SHE'S NOT HERE WILL GO TO FILE
ITEM TO AB.
FIFTY EIGHT THE VOTE CURRENTLY
STANDS -- SIX TWO ZERO KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEE MON.
BILL IS OUT AT SEVEN TWO ZERO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMA [inaudible]
SIX OKAY LET'S GO TO FILE AND
THREE AB. SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN
THREE THE VOTE CURRENTLY THE
BILL IS -- FIVE TWO ZERO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
HIGHLY HI LEE MON.
THE BILL IS AB SEVEN TWO ZERO
RIGHT FILE AND FOR A. B. THREE
THREE EIGHT I THINK ALL THE
MEMBERS ARE HERE -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY NOPE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MON.
FILE ITEM FIVE AB. FOR ELEVEN
FOR ELEVEN THE CURRENCY OF ALL
CURRENTLY IS -- FIVE TWO ZERO
SOME NUMBER KILEY.
KILEY A SOME NOT WEARING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMB ON AND FILE
ITEM SIX A. B. FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
MISS FRIEDMAN.
HOW IS FIVE TWO ZERO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA?
FEDERAL GLORIA I REMEMBER KILEY.
KILEY AYE LIMóN.
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE
ALSO HAD A VOTE ON THE COMMITTEE
RULES -- MORE MATURE WE RECORDED
ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO BE
RECORDED ON THAT.
NO ONE RULES.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
[inaudible]
MR GLORIA.
MISTER MISTER GORE DO YOU WANT
TO VOTE ON THE RULES.
HI GREAT.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FORUM IS THE
MAN WHO I UNDERSTAND IS COMING
DOWN AND APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
WHO [inaudible]
YEAH.
MS LIMON IS HERE.
WE'RE READY -- TO HOWEVER ADD ON
TO I THINK SIX MEASURES AT THIS
TIME FILE ITEM ONE AB TEN
MINUTES A MONTH [inaudible]
HI.
FILE ITEM TO AB FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH IS -- IS REVERSES BILL
MUSSELMAN.
FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE SEVEN
THREE MISTER CHARLES BILL.
FILE IN FOR A BI.
THREE THREE EIGHT FILE IN FIVE
AB.
FOR ELEVEN FILE ITEM SIX AB.
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN AND ON THE
ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE RULES.
SHE WAS HERE GREAT.
OKAY WITH THAT'S WE HAVE
EVERYONE ADDED ON THIS
COMMITTEES NOW ADJOURNED